with the race uh for Glory this is your
second time playing an iconic racing you
know figure and racing history um what
do you think it is about racing movies
that is so compelling and resonates with
audiences well if it's well done like in
this case and also uh in the case of
Rush um it translates the thrill of that
yeah fascinating dangerous um passionate
sport to um to um to the screen um if if
the cinema if the Cinematic translation
works out then um yeah then you delve
into something that is thrilling that is
uh um fast and and crazy when you when
you think about it also the
determination I mean everything that's
behind the the actual sport is like
these freaks who dedicate their life to
to that and um you know are competing so
feverishly uh and are so obsessed by
something this is always fascinating I
guess to to to see people who are so
incredibly obsessed by something um so
that captured me in in in in uh two
times uh that so that I said uh uh yes
and my first instinct was actually no I
said to Ricardo I've done my bits I've
played an iconic driver I don't want to
do another race so just because he's a
friend and he's a very persistent friend
he said no no
no it's not the driver don't worry it's
the aen is a small part but uh because
we're always making fun of each other um
for years now um uh he said this is a
nice opportunity to bring that um to
another level and then uh make fun of us
uh you know Italians versus Germans and
and and um so there was also a lot of
humor uh in in the script what I liked
um and and so I said yes was very glad
you said yes this movie is very great um
something I was thinking about looking
at you know the films that you've done
you have voiced a car you've obviously
uh been Nikki laa now you've been Roland
Gumpert do you have like a personal
connection at all with racing did you
watch you know rally world or F1 growing
up or has it just purely been that your
career has kind of navigated you in that
direction yeah I was into it but not too
much like my brother was a much bigger
Formula 1 fan um he infected me a bit
with a bit with that virus um I always
loved cars I loved old cars and I still
have one an old uh convertible uh uh
pojo
1973 um that never works but uh I can I
cannot sell it because it's I'm so
attached to it so I always liked uh old
cars and then with um yeah also with
rally um I
remember uh I had flashbacks from my
childhood in Spain some of my uncles and
cousins were into that so I remember
sitting on a couch and and watching
these races and thinking as a child why
are the people standing so close uh next
to the to the to the race car I mean
this is insane this is so dangerous but
it was it it it it fascinated me um so
it was a nostalgic ride for me to do
this film and it's something else that I
love about the film how they did it
tonally I mean the texture uh the colors
the costumes the the soundtrack and the
music it all brings you back to the to
the 80s so I was five uh back then in 83
so it it's somehow there was some
moments watching the film also that I
thought like ah this reminds me of my of
my childhood and no that it was nothing
that I was act actively um looking for
it just came to me and at the previous
interview uh um I I was thinking of of
uh one of my favorite scenes that I ever
shot it's in a small German art housee
film called a friend of mine uh where
there's one scene uh where uh me and a
friend are both naked in a Porsche and
we were driving on an on a on a blocked
stretch of the autoban so we could
really go for it uh and I remember that
the cameras were hidden uh behind us uh
with a with with black uh uh cloth so
you couldn't see uh uh anything you just
saw two naked guys in a Porche and we
turned around in a gas station where
there were some kids um who saw us and
it was not you know so they didn't see a
film or anything they saw like what the
hell is going on two
guys driving onto the gas station naked
in a Porche um so uh that was one of the
most memorable scenes in my in my
professional life uh and and yeah uh
cars have always been a part of it for
some reason um but also clearly rush it
it just came to me um and I I was not um
it was it wasn't my dream to play um a
figure in a in in in that in that kind
of world no no I do want to touch on
rush because I love that movie so much
and I love that you've reunited with Ron
Howard on Eden what it's it been like
working with him again 10 years later oh
it's wonderful it's just the same it was
like it's been it was yesterday and I
mean loyalty in our world and our
profession is something that is rare you
know so I remember shooting Rush one day
he said like oh hey Daniel there's um I
really enjoy working with you and
there's a fascinating story about some
guys in the galopus islands uh and I
want to do that with you one day and so
I thought like yeah well Ron is the
nicest guy but will that ever happen I
mean um I I don't think so and now 10
years later I was shooting leld in Paris
when I got a call from him hi this is
Ron I'm in Paris can I visit you on set
and so it's also so sweet that he's
curious in what I'm doing and can I come
to set the French team um um they theyve
I mean they they were so nervous that
Ron was showing up that nothing worked
on that day you know so it was a
complete disaster um um but there he was
uh polite and and and and you know
generous and kind as he was with his
base cap and then and at the end of the
day he said like oh this do you remember
that Galapagos project I'm doing it uh
would you would you be so kind to read
the script and I said Ron man you are
just uh oh you're wonderful and now now
we here with an incredible cast um Felix
being one of them uh and uh yeah just
had some couple of scenes with Jude Law
this this week uh he's an
incredible actor and man he's so
passionate and and um his energy is so
contagious it's wonderful uh working
with him it's my first time uh that I
have the pleasure to be working with him
H it's it's an absolute blast uh and so
it is with Vanessa with Anna the Aras
Sydney Sweeney I mean it's a it's a
stellar cast to Wallace um so I'm really
having a great time and and Ron hasn't
changed uh a bit um he's still the same
yeah I was going to ask you know over
the last 10 years what has changed for
you as an actor that you were like
excited to bring to this project like
where have you like matured in your
career and found new things that you've
been able to bring to this film it's
becoming more and more interesting for
me personally as an as an actor I have
to say becoming older the parts are
becoming more interesting this is
sometimes I had it I mean I had a very
good kickoff when I was young young but
then I always looked younger than I
actually was so there was a stretch of a
couple of years in my late 20s than I
thought thought like I still get these
scripts where I have to play someone who
is has the problems of a 19-year-old but
I'm 29 so playing a coming of age you
know so I was I was B frustrated by by
that and now I think it's becoming
better and better uh more complex and uh
the parts are more mature and and you
know it's uh different Stakes different
uh dilemas different conflicts that
you're allowed to you know uh portray
it's it's it's
um uh it's more faceted and and and and
um more intense um also you know playing
Lagerfeld was such an interesting ride
this year I always love when you feel
slightly out of your comfort zone when
in the minute you say yes to something
you go like oh how am I going to do
this H you know you know this is what
gives you the kick you know um and so um
yeah I hope that it
stays uh like that I hope that Ron along
the process says hey
Daniel in 10 years from
now we should do this and that I mean I
don't I cannot think of a project now
this but um uh yeah uh so um I'm happy
that after I mean I started when I was
roughly when I was
15 or 16 the fact that I'm still here
that I'm that we are still talking which
means that apparently there's something
to talk about that I'm still doing films
and I'm I'm I'm I'm working is already
uh uh wonderful because it's it's it's
tough and it's difficult to stay in the
game it's it's um so you can always say
you know knock knock knock on wood that
it's stays like that definitely and as
we wrap up I did want to ask about
another one of your projects we just saw
the first footage for the franchise last
week which I'm very excited for I love
the plot of that I've worked on
superhero movies so like that plot is
very like right off my alley oh I mean I
I I honestly I and the English and
Americans when they because that's what
we don't have in Germany we are not
really funny uh some of the guys who
think they're funny are not funny I mean
I it was never my cup of tea so I always
bow my hat uh um even the austrians
Felix is f i mean the austrians are
funny but so I was always trying to get
a foot in in you know a top comedy uh
but it's very difficult for a German and
also I said a trillion times to Sam
menis thanks for choosing a German
because I'm the only one who's not
English or American he was looking for a
director uh could be from anywhere and
so when he said yes eventually uh I said
oh my God thank you and and Sam said you
know you're very funny for being a
German you're in fact and so uh and so
when we shot the pilot it was we had so
much fun it's a dangerous one though
it's one of those where you have to be
careful to not crack up uh whilst you're
doing it uh there's some of these actors
that oh God I suffered so much with
Richard ER Grand with with Billy
Magnuson because just by looking at them
and he meshed that just they you know
crack me up and it's the hilarious
writing and the the quality of you know
uh Sam mandz yuci and and Brown from
succession I mean these three guys
together the Perfection of the of of the
sense of humor of the punch lines of the
timing is to me is an absolute gift and
as you said I also have had my
experiences in that in that universe so
so it's it's just a you know it's it's a
lot of fun yeah I'm very excited for
that one um I wanted to thank you again
for uh chatting with me about this I'm
very excited for race for Glory and what
people will say about it pleasure thank
thank you
Daniel